and as those numbers they just come as a
reminder as we start to let our guard
down get back to normal lives the
vaccine just like other vaccines is not
100 percent
effective it does offer some protection
but not immunity
so there is a small chance you can still
get the virus as sally jaramillo reports
that's why there's still a push to get
vaccinated and continue to get tested
sally yes denise and even though the
number of deaths are dropping we still
have to remember
last year we lost over 600 000 americans
in clark county the southern nevada
health district is monitoring the spread
of delta and other kova 19 variants
and based on recent lab reports the
delta variant is currently
not the predominant variant in clark
county i spoke to michael gartner the
vice dean
of clinical affairs for the kirk
kerkorian school of medicine at unlv
what he is seeing is those still not
vaccinated are the ones getting sick and
spreading the virus
with being more than six months into the
year we should be seeing more than half
the population vaccinated
in the state instead the positivity rate
is rising
even the new delta variant that people
are very worried about and rightly so
if you've had particularly the pfizer or
modern vaccine the mrna vaccines
it seems to be 98 99
effective in preventing you from getting
either infected or at least an infection
you would know about
currently there are no recommendations
from federal authorities regarding a
booster vaccination dose
at this time but garner believes it's
highly likely we may need one
and are still determining when exactly
as for wearing mass in nevada we have
not seen an increase in admissions and
icu admissions yet
that's why if you are fully vaccinated
except when you are in healthcare
situations or if you are on public
transportation like planes
masks aren't required reporting in the
newsroom sally jaramillo 8 news now
so we asked on twitter does the recent
uptick in cases make you want to wear a
mask again well this one was pretty
close
45 percent saying yes they'd like to
mask up 55 percent
saying no